I also think it was particularly  tasteless to for those who are grieving  a mother an MP and a friend to say that  the best way to honor her memory is to  deliver the thing that she and her  family campaigned against which is  brazen I know he did and I think I think  it was a nun very tasteless way of  referring to the memory of a murdered MP  murdered by somebody who said Britain  first who is obviously of the far-right  tendency which you could argue is being  whipped up by this sort of language my  brother's using words like surrendered  capitulation as if the people who are  standing in the way of the Blessed will  of the people as defined by the  seventeen point four million votes in  2016 should be hung drawn and quartered  tarred and feathered and I think that is  highly reprehensible language to use and  I hope that today in the comments were  recording this on Thursday there will be  some sort of deal on both sides all  sides that this sort of thing is utterly  dialed down